[Musique]
dans six cas relevant jour vous êtes
présidente balima membres du conseil
exécutif de la 7e et candidats pour les
législatives à fort de france c'est bien
ça absolument et bonjour à toutes et à
tous et je suis en fait le robot à table
derrière ce colosse qui n'est pas
seulement le pari mois mais le même le
techniques écologiques de plus on
appelle le grand ensemble et ce qu'on
appelle le grand ensemble et moi c'est
moi c'est une des nez une unité voilà
c'est le rdr on voit on verra ça dans
notre dans notre émission déjà avant
tout au pas de charge votre analyse du
gouvernement macron non c'est
l'important c'est de voir les objectifs
de ce gouvernement aux cats ont analysé
des projets de mâcon on se rend compte
que c'est un projet très très libérale
et on s'était bien sûr beaucoup de
choses notamment sur est ce que
deviendront et et le code du travail et
la situation des travailleurs et on
s'interroge aussi sur un système que
nous avons aujourd'hui à plat ce qui est
que la diminution des dotations de
l'état s'accentue
nous avons perdu perdu à peu près entre
2003 et 2007 après 26 millions d'euros
de perte de dotation
c'est important et la crainte que j'ai
c'est que ce gouvernement ne continue la
même la même politique était celle de
monsieur hollande et politique qui a été
approuvée d'ailleurs massivement par le
député sortant de fort de france pour
vous il faut changer
le des chantiers des manuels mâcon c'est
la moralisation de la vie politique
qu'en pense y voit ce qu'il faut changer
l'organisation de la vie politique
à l'entraînement on attend souvent
d'ailleurs depuis des décennies et que
tous les présidents qui arrivent au
pouvoir se fixe comme objectif de
moraliser la vie publique de moraliser
la vie politique est en fête et non des
restes à 2 qu'il ya des choses qui sont
faites qui permettait sans doute
d'améliorer les choses mais je pense que
la moralisation de la vie politique ce
ne sont pas que des ce ne sont pas que
des lois bien entendu les lois sont
importantes mais c'est la conception que
nous avons de l'action politique
si l'action politique est un moyen de
s'enrichir si la vie politique est un
moyen d'avoir de l'influencé dans les
milieux d'affaires quoique ces golfs et
je crois qu'il ya une connexion
aujourd'hui entre les milieux d'affaires
les milieux de la finance et la
politique qui est inévitablement une
situation qui entraîne les dires il que
nous connaissons notre candidat à fort
de france
est ce que comme le disait à cette même
place mercredi s'il va essayer ce talent
votre principal adversaire c'est
l'abstention
aujourd'hui est que mon principal
adversaire c'est évidemment le député
sortant ce que c'est lui qui était là
elle a mené une politique qui n'a pas
est tellement aidé la marque et que ce
prix là la tension ce que je vous disais
qu'il a voté toutes les lois
antisociales de l'ancien président a par
contre l'abstention est une donnée
données sociologiques évidemment nous
faisons tout pour ce qui nous concerne
dans les quartiers pour mobiliser la
population foyalaise parce
qu'effectivement il ya des risques
d'adaptation mais je crois surtout qu'il
faut que les martin qui comprennent
qatar ces moments là d'un des moments
aussi important il faut aller voter
aller voter massivement d'autant que
nous avons une offre au pôle tes kind of
et diversifiée plus de 10 candidats fort
de france ici un peu beaucoup comme on
le dit alors et c'est beaucoup c'est
même toit de 14-14 louis quatorze 14
candidats sur le français c'est beaucoup
alors évidemment est a priori on peut ne
pas s'en plaindre parce que ça voudrait
dire que la démocratie y est
dynamique le livre etc mais en même
temps la question est de savoir ce que
chacun apporte dans le débat général
et si chacun est bien préparé à ce type
de à ce type de démarche
s'il ne s'agit pas de se présenter pour
se présenter mais en même temps on ne
peut pas se plaindre parce qu'il ya des
gens qui viennent et qui se présente ce
que l'on vous reproche c'est de courir
vous élus à la ce et tmc de courir après
les mans après les mandats à peine élu à
la ctn certaines personnes donc vous
reproche de vouloir déjà briguer le
fauteuil de député
est ce que vous entendez ça s couperont
comprenait alors ce que je dis
simplement c'est que pour ce qui me
concerne ce n'est pas la première fois
que ses candidats aux élections
législatives
bah c'est pas de caniveau s'étale que ce
candidat aux élections 17 mai ce qui
n'était pas autant à dire c'est que nous
avons mis en place une septième
nous avons des finir ce tour
d'orientation sur le plan économique le
plan social le plan du sport mais il
nous faut parce que ce pays est un
département français ce n'est pas un
état contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait
imaginer ce n'est pas un état
indépendant
c'est un département et il ya c'est donc
deux décisions qui se prennent à travers
des lois et ses lois sont prises à
l'assemblée nationale française et aussi
d'un nouveau parlement
par contre il faut absolument que les
ceux qui défendent les orientations de
que nous mettons en oeuvre aujourd'hui
soit présent à l'assemblée nationale
pour faire valoir les est également
appliquée pour porter la voix de la 7e
et pour se poser en défenseur des
intérêts martiniquaise je pense que
c'est très important
nous ne pouvons pas alors que nous avons
la majorité dans l'ensemble du pays nous
est laissé aux présentées par d'autres
qui aujourd'hui aujourd'hui est bien là
le action c'est plus de contrecarrer
l'action de la 7e la ctn a besoin
d'interlocuteurs auprès de l'état
français est au pouvoir aussi de
l'assemblée nationale et nous
considérons qu'il nous faut être là
qu'il ya par conséquent nécessité
politique une jante que le droit
semblait soient représentés à
l'assemblée nationale si vous êtes élu
vous pouvez vous allez rester à
l'exécutif à ce que c'est possible ça
alors il ya il ya plusieurs lois qui se
contredisent d'abord doigté sortant 2011
qui disait que les conseillers exécutifs
avait et rang de conseillers régionaux
par conséquent qu'il n'y avait pas de
contradiction
une deuxième loi a opposé justement ea a
montré et l'incompatibilité entre eux
la fonction de conseiller exécutif et de
deux députés
et puis quand on regarde et le récemment
des derniers textes sortis paix
concernant des élections et le memento
et des quads que cette règle des
compatibilités ne serait applicable ne
serait applicable qu'au renouvellement
de l'assemblée
donc ce qui voudrait dire par conséquent
que pour ce mandat il n'y aurait pas de
difficulté à cumuler les deux postes
je lui dis quoi ceci étant et la
question de la décision politique est
autre chose comment vous imaginez votre
rôle à l'assemblée si vous êtes élu
alors si je suis élu je crois qu'il ya
cet homme de dossiers urgents que tout
le monde connaît sont les dossiers qui
sont liées à la santé à la prise en
charge de la santé des martiniquais donc
d'une part la situation de la conception
qui est développé autour de l'hôpital
c'est un premier élément deuxièmement
toujours matière de santé l'importance
de la prévention que nous voulons nous
voyons qu'il y à cette aune de
pathologies qui reviennent souvent qui
se développe notamment l'obésité et le
diabète l'hypertension il faut une très
élégant c'est aussi il faut une très
forte politique de prévention
ça c'est très important nous avons
commencé à faire un certain nombre le
sol mais il faut aller beaucoup plus
loin à terme de loi la deuxième chose
c'est évidemment tout ce qui a trait à
l'éducation j'ai toujours considéré que
l'éducation est elle le moyen de sortir
un certain nombre de jeunes des
situations que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui
il faut donner un certain nombre de
moyens pour encadrer pour accompagner
troisième élément qui est essentielle
je considère que toute une série de
difficultés que nous avons aujourd'hui
en matière de chômage et qui a posé une
question centrale c'est la question du
développement
quel développement de boulot pour la
martinique il faut sortir de l'ancien
modèle économique nous avons commencé à
travailler sur un schéma territorial et
de développement économiques et des
terres nationalisation et d'innovation
qui en janvier a été présenté et hier
mais il faut bien comprendre que pour
permettre la mutation économique dont
nous avons besoin
il faut que l'état aussi prenne ses
responsabilités alors de la grande
coalition du grand ensemble et pumba
pays en chance donc la coloration et
énergie il ya plusieurs candidats qui se
présentent à fort-de-france marie-france
tools du grand ensemble et manque du rdm
et megal aventures des fmp by chance et
de la droite
en ce sens les gatti des candidatures
qui vous gêne notamment celle de marie
france tous non ça nous sommes mais ce
n'est nullement et tout le monde peut se
présenter je faisais l'éloge de la
participation la plus large possible à
ses excuses aux banshee nullement je
n'ai pas contre ce que j'ai toujours dit
de manière responsable c'est que dans le
cas de la gorge c'est à dire de ceux qui
ont gagné les
des postes importants au niveau des
élections municipales
ceux qui ont aussi réussi une percée
importante lors des élections
territoriales que dans le cas de fausse
parce que font deux faces a ceci de
particulier qu'il est à la fois et une
section de la collectivité une commune
une circonscription électorale
donc ce sont les mêmes personnes qui
votent donc dans ce cas j'ai toujours
prôné l'unité la plage parce que je
pense que c'est une élève brillante elle
s'est en effet ne s'est pas faite pour
cela est une erreur pour je considère
que ce n'est pas ce n'est pas là le bon
choix
ceci étant je prends acte et du
positionnement de chacun et je n'ai pas
en dire davantage
vous espérez qu'au deuxième tour s'il ya
un deuxième tour tout le monde va se
retrouver derrière votre candidat n'est
rien n'est véritablement au deuxième
tour du doigt un regroupement entre
parce que c est un acte ii
d'évidence politique en actes
d'intelligence politique parce que
n'oublions pas les aspects pouvoir de la
droite également
je n'espérais j'espère que les électeurs
se rassemble autour de moi parce que
sous la base n'ont pas de moi en tant
qu'individu mais des orientations que je
propose est du grand mouvement que
citoyen de nouveau look et pour changer
les choses parce que nous considérons
que d'une manière générale qu une même
équipe est au pouvoir 72 ans eh bien ça
fait trop et il faut absolument sortir
le sortant francis carole je vous
remercie et moi qui vous remercie
bonne journée à l écoute de nos
programmes
[Musique]